so here's where we were we were saying
this abstraction of the neuron is valid
at least for one type of neuron a big
beautiful Purkinje cell this type of
model seems to be a better model for
neurons with long that are different
from terrestrial trees every time you
look at a tree now I want you to I want
you to think about this how those most
terrestrial trees seem to have this
Purkinje cell like shape where most of
the stuff is a little twigs
whereas pyramidal neurons especially
human ones they're most of the stuff is
on there's a little bit of branching and
then with these long unbranched sections
which create kind of little subunits and
so for those types of cells a two layer
model is more appropriate where you
think and and where they kind of act
independently of each other the
non-linearity acts independently on this
stuff in this dendrite and then it adds
up with a supplement that helpful for
that dendrite and that's the output of a
neuron but branching wander should be
the same story basic you it isn't it
isn't it if the nmda spikes and actually
misses are the dynamics or is it really
the non-branching that makes this
supplement no no it's not it's well it
if you could have very branched things
with NMDA channels and there will be
local spikes generated it's just somehow
the logic of these cells seems to be to
put a set of inputs onto this dendrite
which will interact closely and under
the same non-linearity and different
from the inputs to a different dendrite
I'm not saying that it has to be long
unbranched sections I'm just saying that
they happen to be in the case of
pyramidal neurons what's the cause for
why would it want to be that way
reason I mean you say the observe these
neurons and they're somewhat in some
sense they build compartments
compartments but what's really the
reason the functional reason for this
compartment civilization are you saying
what is the computational benefit of
having multiple compartments I mean we
say if it's a grandstand right but still
because right could still have well this
is really could still be a valid model
for a branch for neuron will with
branches so it's it doesn't seem to be
this long unbranched okay
um let me just make a relatively weak
statement so that it doesn't bother you
pyramidal neuron dendrites are largely
or have art often or characterized by
having tending to have long unbranched
sections they will be like kind of
functional subunits other architectures
are possible okay now here's a problem
with the this two layer model remember
well let me see if I come up here
this says that there is a sigmoid in
this dendrite it's a sigmoid Olympic
output function now is that a valid
abstraction and and it and it says that
by the way that the inputs to a dendrite
add and it doesn't matter where they are
they're just a big it's a big collector
and in that dendrite and the inputs kind
of add up and then they go into the
sigmoid so there's no sense of a
location like a synapse being at this
location versus that location having a
different effect so let's see what about
the validity of that so this was an
experiment done there's a recording at
the cell body these are the voltage with
traces that are being recorded and there
was a IO to phoresis of glutamate in
these experiments so glutamates being
kind of squirted out onto these
dendrites to stimulate them you know to
stimulate the glutamatergic synapses at
different different places but at one
place let's say that corresponds to this
place the cell there's the stimulation
has turned up and turned up and turned
up and it's kind of creating a series of
curves like you saw before with the
uncaging this is meant to phoresis and
here's a spike that's generated and if
you were to do the same thing closer
into the cell body then you get this
trace now the reason is it's because the
same thing is basically happening at
that point of the dendrite but because
you did it closer there's less
attenuation of the voltage moving in
towards the cell body so you see a
bigger signal and if you did it farther
away you would see sort of this kind of
a pattern it's little sub-threshold
things and the spike is generate but the
spike looks really tiny that far out not
because this bike is tiny out where it
is but because it has two voltage
attenuates a lot on the way in and if
you look at if you kind of generated
input output curves like the amount of
input and then you plot it against the
voltage that occurred for the peak
folders that occurred you'd get
something like this you'd get a low
threshold low amplitude sigmoid for this
position medium and large sigmoid for a
different position so even within one
dendrite you've got three sigmoids that
are have varying thresholds and
amplitudes which is not part of the
paradigm of a typical like neural
network units
so that's already that's already
something that we have to contend with
so what it what it the question that
raises is okay that's already kind of
breaks our paradigm but then let's let's
go one step let's let's do what's the
next experiment you want to do you want
to take two inputs and you want to vary
their locations and look at how they
combine so you could what one thing we
could ask is let's just consider two
locations like call one a driver to
modulator I can flip it it doesn't
really matter that's a semantic term
here and you might you were just
interested in what is the symmetry or
asymmetry between a proximal and distal
location on on one dendrite we know we
know that they will individually behave
differently but what is the what is the
symmetry or asymmetry of the interaction
between those two inputs when you apply
them together and it could be that you
could have an input-output curve of the
driver and then as the modulator is
increased it could do something like yes
it could lower the threshold without
changing the amplitude it could change
the gain essentially but without
changing the threshold and it could do
some kind of a combination of those I
mean we don't know so this is this is
the question to ask what about multiple
inputs that are spatially delocalized
are spatially separated so there are a
couple of papers we collaborated with
Jackie Shiller again some of my former
students Vardi abeja body monica jadi
worked on these modeling aspect of it
too to kind of look at this question and
in a joint experimental and modeling
context and here with the way the
experiments were kind of like we saw
before where there was uncaging or well
uncaging or electrical stimulation at
two sites on a real dendrite and there
was a recording made at the cell body
and then then the electrodes would be
activated at different levels well
actually the toppling was meant to be a
model and the bottom ones meant to be
the experiment and here you can see an
input/output curve
different levels of activity of the
distal input eventually generates a
little spike at a certain threshold
level of intensity you're in an
experiment and they're in a model and
then if that curve is repeated in the
context of a
of a proximal input that is increased to
generate a new curve is generated and
it's increasing again a new chapter is
generated what you see in the model is
that there's a there's a left shifting
of the threshold of the sigmoid and an
increase in the excursion and increase
in this sort of takeoff point so it's
sort of a characteristic progression of
these sigmoid Olimpo topic Ertz
generated by the distal input in the
context of an ever-larger proximal bias
or a proximal modulating input and in
the experiments it was very similar the
DISA limpid by itself would generate a
little sigmoid and then the sigmoid sort
of shifted to the left and became and
the spikes became bigger in excursion
and sort of having a longer take or a
higher take-off point so it was a very
similar pattern and then if you so the
effect of a proximal modulator is to
sort of do is to modulate the input
output curve of the other input of a
distal input in that particular way and
then if you do it if you kind of do with
the opposite experiment you use this one
as the driver and then you generate it
and put up a curve and then you do it in
the presence of an ever-larger distal
input to generate a series of curves
then you get a very different pattern
you get this patterns where there's a
left shifting of the sigmoid with no
change in the amplitude and eventually
kind of a linearization of the input
output curve and that's what happens
here there's a left shift in the input
output curve with well maybe a slight
degradation in the amplitude but then
eventually this linearization occurs and
so that's the effect of a distal
modulator on a proximal input is no
increase in the excursion size but a
left shifting of the sigmoid so it's an
AZ it's an interesting and strange
asymmetry that all of the data together
comparing model and data sort of said
the same thing so actually you here let
me let me just go to here so here's a
plot of that if you do this in a model
and you take approximately the distal
input you proximal but there's this lump
up there and you plot the response at
the cell body what you see is a
two-dimensional asymmetric sigmoid --all
function that's what the dendrite does
when you put two inputs in that are not
at the same place
that is not any simple generalization of
a 1d sigmoid is it it's a 2d
non-linearity it depends on the location
of the in card
interestingly and I think this is very I
think this should be compelling to you
many of you can turn people who like to
make models of things this surface is
produced by this circuit which has five
conductances in it
this model has you know a full
compartmental model thousands I don't
know I don't know how many 443
compartments each compartment we have
many differential equations they're all
coupled it's very nonlinear there's NMDA
channels AMPA channels cable properties
etc morphology and that produces this
input/output curve and this is produced
by five conductances with no time at all
this is all steady-state so it's a
virtually perfect reproduction of what
one thin dendrite does with NMDA
channels for delocalized inputs it
produces an asymmetric 2d sigmoid now
does anybody think that's weird you do
yeah it's kind of it's kind of
interesting it's like what the heck is a
2-d sigmoid for and let's say symmetric
but what what I like about this is that
this extremely simple model captures the
behavior of a very complicated model
very well in that respect so we also
took this now maybe this is an artifact
of so real neurons actually generate
action potentials not just 10 millivolt
excursions from resting potential so
what about when this thing is taken up
into the to a range of intensity of
stimulation so that the cell is firing
action potentials shall I pause before I
finish my sentence or you want it well
just to say it's the same it's a very
similar pattern when the cells producing
action potentials here's the distal
input by itself produces so now that now
the two inputs are bunches of synapses
being activated by trains of action
potentials and they're you know so the
synapses are being repeatedly activated
there's noise being injected to the cell
body so that sort of simulate in vivo
like conditions and then the membrane
potential is measured at the cell body
and what the output is now is not what's
how much voltage is caused its how many
spikes per second are caused and that's
plotted on this axe
here but again you have a little sigmoid
caused by the distal input a big sigmoid
caused by the proximal input and this
kind of pushy asymmetric sigmoid 'el
sing in between and as before the effect
of the proximal modulator is the sort of
left shift to threshold and increase the
excursion and and the effect of a distal
modulator is to left shift the threshold
and with no increase in the excursion
and that's the same asymmetry that we
saw before
yes all right so when you have two
inputs on the right like that and
co-active when did you expect
they weren't distant but to be more
effective because it's it's it's current
would be shunted on the way to go so the
cell planet because of the synaptic
conductance about or approximately and
that one wouldn't work the other way
around
you're saying the distal input should be
more effective no I'm saying that the
effect of having two inputs activated at
the same time as you get a conductance
at both points and the current flow from
the nearer one is not going to be so
affected by the more distal end point
but the more dissonant but will be
shunted more but there's something
suggest a reduction of but actually
there's a synergy because these are NMDA
channels and they both I can understand
the synergy but is it that I would have
thought the conductance would have a
bigger effect on a more distal point
well you know this is let me let me let
me escape from this by saying that those
those kind of word pictures the ones
that you're trying to construct and that
we tried to construct for months and
months and have still do are very
difficult to make work I think so I it's
very difficult to take - to put into
words all of the things that go on
inside the cable with NMDA channels in a
way that you'll remember for more than
three seconds and be able to use so the
way that I boiled this down in my mind
is I say if you were to have two inputs
to a dendrite that are NMDA champ that
head to activate NMDA conductances and
you have a cable there then you're going
to get an asymmetric to sigmoid a
relationship and I kind of understand I
understand this curve I understand this
curve and what happens in between is
kind of smooth and that's about as far
as my intuition can carry me
we can you know we can sometimes get a
little bit more insight into a little
you know if you wanna if we ask a very
specific question but in terms of kind
of breaking it into reducing it in terms
of simple concepts is very difficult and
wait and when inhibition comes in it
becomes it becomes even harder I mean
let me let me let me show you what I
could be so these are these are examples
of like okay let's go to the simulation
and let's take one of these in these
asymmetric 2d services start playing
with some of the parameters we could
have different separations we could have
synaptic facility we could model
synapses that have slightly different
properties that facilitate we could have
spines with different neck resistances
there's a the point is that the
biological parameters that are available
to the neuron
provide for a rich set of these
nonlinear asymmetric multi-dimensional
sigmoid 'el interaction functions that
that could be can be made okay and
that's that's what the hardware can do
and does do even just for two inputs and
here's here's the case where even the
synapses that are moving along this axis
don't even have NMDA channels so if you
take those out you can nonetheless get a
input/output curve that is linear but
that is whose gain is increased by the
other module Ettore input which does
have NMDA channels so there's a there's
there's just a lot of different a lot of
different possibilities and that's kind
of what we see our job is doing a little
bit as to sort of work out what the
parameters make of it that actually
exist in the biology and in these cells
make available to you the you the brain
designer out there who is trying to use
these this kind of biophysical
mechanisms in order to compute something
there's there's a lot of flexibility so
inhibition people have asked so it turns
out it's maybe a lucky thing but if you
were to have another input two inputs
and one of them as an inhibitory input
it turns out to have a kind of a similar
but anti parallel effect as excitation
so that whereas this is the case of
proximal inhibition what it does is it
has it has
significant there's a slight elevation
of the threshold and a significant
depression of the of the excursion and
distal inhibition has the effect of
raising the threshold without changing
the excursion so it's kind of doing the
opposite of what the excitation was
doing in that place and the same for in
a model so to understand to understand
the combination to understand excitation
and inhibition both you can kind of
think about them and I I as I say this I
I really I'm very cautious to say this
because it probably won't turn out to be
true in all cases and I don't even know
I don't know how general this will turn
out to be but anyway in the least the
simple cases that we looked at there
seem to be kind of an opposite opponent
see to this where if you were to put an
excitatory modulator on distally you
know you're driving it with this black
input here and then you use this as a
distal what we expect this to do is to
lower the threshold and it does it makes
it lower the threshold without without
changing the excursion and then if you
just put an inhibitory synapse there it
kind of does the opposite maybe not in
equal amounts but it does the opposite
if you do combine them together then
they kind of cancel so that's it's
creating a little bit of a sense that
there's an arithmetic that isn't crazy
between excitation inhibition they kind
of both obey the same location dependent
rules and they kind of cancel out each
other's effects or they they go in
opposite directions to your point of
like how do you you know how do you do
positive and negative things and and so
on this is these are these are opposite
direction modulatory effects this is the
same sort of a deal where a proximal
modulator if excitatory does this kind
of a shift to an input up a curve and a
just and a proximal modulator that is
inhibitory it sort of pushes you lower
in amplitude and further to the right
these two didn't perfectly cancel in
this case but they kind of sort of
cancelled if you put them both on at the
same time so that's that's that there's
some logic to this but and and and you
can sort of now see that the
possibilities for using excitation
inhibition in different locations to to
modulate responses nonlinearly are
wonderfully rich though this is a
cartoon from a model but it summarizes
the experiment
this actually this model may have been
done in matlab using just representing
the NMD channels in a simple cable I
can't remember how which one what Monica
did on this particular one so now what
I'm trying to put into words what I just
said in terms of what opportunities this
biophysical mechanism of having a
dendrite that's nonlinear cable NMDA
channels excitation inhibition that can
go to different places but not the
opportunities that that provides to the
cortex to do things to the neuron what
opportunities are there well a neuron
that is going to affect this neuron with
some kind of a module Ettore input now
has the choice of steering its contacts
closer to the cell body farther from the
cell body uniformly whatever it wants to
do it has the it has the opportunity to
do that and this is done as Marie will
tell you in like in the thalamus there's
gonna be inputs of target distally well
actually in almost any neuron there are
neurons that have chosen to target
distal approximately this here or there
that is a capability that the brain has
to steer inputs proximally and distally
and by doing so these ma zouri effects
can be steered or or tailored and the
inhibition so this is interesting
because the inhibition is different
where there are dedicated neurons which
target proximal and distal locations but
then the pathway can choose the degree
to which it activates one of those to
affect the amount of proximal versus
distal and abyssion that will be applied
to the neuron and i want to show one
example of this there's a lot of kind of
excitement in recent years as the
ability to label different types of
neurons has increased with different
kind of molecular markers genetic you
know viruses and so on can can light up
different classes of inter neurons so
here's a pyramidal neuron this is a part
of your larval human containing
inhibitory interneuron which tend to
target the cell body of pyramidal
neurons this is a somatostatin
containing neuron which tend to target
the dendrites of parents and tend to
inhibit for P V neurons so there are
these circuits which the circuit motifs
like this which have been proven
shown demonstrated tested etc and you
know when you look at this and you think
about what what what I've just been
talking about these proximal distal
interaction effects you now see that
well okay a module Ettore here's a
neuron which is off you know outside
let's call it the receptive field of
this neuron and it's but it's axons run
over and make contact by steering a
contacts to different distances from the
soma it can have very different effects
from game modulating effects to
threshold modulating effects similarly
that by activating and these these
contacts do make contact onto these
cells they do make contact onto these
inter neurons these inter neurons
inhibit they inhibit the inhibitors and
so actually if you look at the logic of
this this what by inhibit a somatostatin
neuron by being excited delivers
inhibition here and it also reduces the
amount of inhibition here so what you do
by activating this medicine second
neuron as you take the inhibition which
was mostly at the soma and you shove it
mostly to the to the dendrite so there's
what does that do you know so we we
actually simulated that case to see what
that did and we kind of had an idea we
followed the logic that we had built up
from from from our from these
biophysical all kind of studies and if
we had just if we just sort of erased
the whole inhibitory interneuron circuit
and we just considered this modulator
affecting this and this driver in this
modulator the drivers distal the
modulator is proximal then we get one of
those curves those those 2d surfaces
like I showed you before and if you
slice it up you get a curves like this
with that that characteristic sort of
left shifting and steepening of the of
the input and output curve but if you
put the circuit in place these two weird
things happen which is that as these as
the modulator increases it keeps putting
out more and more distal inhibition
which pushes these curves progressively
each one the further further this one
goes further to the right this is a
little less far and so on and it tends
to line up the curves with each other
and then because you're relieving
progressively relieving the cell body of
inhibition you have a lot of suppression
on the first curve and little not very
much depression the last curve so you
end up with this kind of high dynamic
range multiplicative scaling of the
input output curve
see other words this curve looks like a
small version of like this curves like
three times the value vector so it looks
it takes a kind of a complicated looking
pattern and turns it into a simpler
looking multiplicative scaling so we
don't know if this is what that circuit
is really for but it kind of you know
it's possible that one of the uses or
one of the ways in which the cortex uses
these types of local circuits is to just
exactly tailor the you know tailor the
the modular Tory effect to be something
other than you know an excitatory only
effect would look like this and one that
includes these inhibitory motifs would
be of a different nature and I just we
just kind of explored whether
multiplicative scaling which is a very
common operation in many computations
would possibly be the result and we kind
of that that was a very convenient thing
for this kind of a circuit to do yes
a response like spikes per second
I'm sorry this should be
by coming to be taken into account well
that's a good question
but you remember that I said that we
were kind of looking at a rate version
of this in the minute you introduced
spike timing I mean anything can be
different I mean you can have spikes
that don't overlap in time with each
other and there's no interaction of
anything to anything so we'd have to
when you wanted to with spike timing
questions you have to kind of be very
specific about what scenario exactly are
you talking about because it won't it
will matter yes episode mm having just
taken apart to the point of this circuit
song being torn so forth which but it's
actually critical well well
multiplicative making this curve be a
scaled version of this curve you can
sort of see intuitively you kind of need
to line up the threshold so you need to
push them ever closer to the right and
you need to have and then you'd like to
have as large a kind of a dynamic range
as you could get so this is by no means
the only way that you could get a gain
effect in a neuron you know the apical
tuft is a way to do it
chanson Abbott's proposal was a way to
do it
there they were basically just turning
up an inhibitory conductance and there
was noise and they did it so and that
didn't have anything to do with
dendrites at all in fact they were point
neurons if I remember so it this is just
pointing out that a modulo Torian put in
the cortex has a lot of flexibility
including this effect but including a
large spectrum of other cases as needed
yes it takes into account it there's so
much fewer about booming and semester
that you wouldn't compare to there two
three pyramids so when you look at many
of the circuits now they must share this
probably minimal
so then you have a higher dimensional
computation and do effects taking place
right rather than you're looking at just
this local projection that you consider
in this curves here yeah so what you're
saying is that Wolfgang is that this
cell will target multiple cells and the
cell target multiple cells and so it is
it's not like this is a dedicated inter
neuron in this circuit yes that's
absolutely true
yes and so this is by no means an
explanation of how cortical circuits
work it's what we're trying to do is try
to identify the parameters available to
neurons and the neurons next to those
neurons to affect each other
you know so that we can understand like
how do you build up computations with
this kind of hardware and we just kind
of what we're really in an you know when
you start to get a circuit that's
complicated but we're not modeling these
neurons in a sophisticated way if we did
it in a sophisticated way things might
change you know it's just it's kind of
scary there's a lot of there's a lot of
flexibility here but then again you know
we have to find the sources of
flexibility if you think about the
cortex this you know if you and most of
us looked under the microscope but a
piece of cortex had just picked it out
of the brain at a random you wouldn't
know where you were looking because it
all looks pretty similar I mean you know
there yes there are some differences
that even you know on I might see as an
on train tuner Anonymous but it's kind
of an architecture that that has been
conserved and n is used and has some
parameters changed but those parameters
can be changed so that that machine can
process visual images process sounds
process whisker inputs which come in
over time process tastes produce
language produce thoughts produce
planning you know I mean produce
emotions this is one basic architecture
whose parameters can be changed to do
all of those things better than we know
how to do any of them so there's got to
be some flexibility there and that's
what we're trying to do is sort of
figure out where you know where it's
hiding and and here's the place where
some flexibilities this to tailor the
amount of excitation that goes here and
they are detailed amount of inhibition
that goes here here etc
this is interesting you probably know
but nobody seems to know this I found
this and I'm bragging right I found it
not like I read the paper but they found
it in in in in primates there is a
system of inhibitory interneurons that
is extremely spatially localized it's
it's very numerous if this is the top so
this is the cortex and these inhibitory
neurons that's they're shown here
they're called double bouquets cells
they have they they have these very
narrow columnar axons that that are like
a little 10 micron sort of cylinder
which is a small moon this is like maybe
a hundred hundred microns or something a
hundred fifty microns this is a 10
micron cylinder this goes up and down
makes inhibitory contacts on to one a
little bit of a dendrite and then then
there's another then you move over 20
microns and you get another one this is
this is a top view of the columns and
this is the side view of the columns of
these axons so they produce this kind of
a grid of inhibition that targets
everything that it targets it targets in
the localized way so there's localized
inhibition happening on different
dendrites imagine that you're sticking
out your branches like this and you're
going through these kind of columns of
light or something and you cut into them
at different places depending on which
dendrite goes where and so you're
receiving focal inhibition at different
points on different dendrites and you
know maybe this is a way of producing
diversity so that different dendrites
can act like you know can can have
different sorts of
you know I think this is actually that I
didn't plug my computer and that's I
hope that it doesn't need much more than
just me pushing a button that a second
I'll just oh extemporize here for a
second
this grid produces a very very intricate
pattern of inhibition in the cortex and
nobody knows what that's for
but knowing that there are spatial
integration effects that are nonlinear
and location dependent makes that a
significant fact
it's about the grid it sounds like the
double bouquet cells are going
vertically you said something else is
going horizontally well if you take a
camel neuron the great majority of the
contacts that land on to a parameter on
are not vertical axons coming to drive
the cell with sensory information let's
say in the sensory are their horizontal
connections coming from other parameter
learns something like 70% so the there's
this the cortex seems to be designed to
produce to provide the opportunities for
extremely intricate lateral modulatory
effects where cells interact non
linearly with each other or they affect
each other
I got it perfect you know you the panic
thank you Apple and whoever else
portal :
see that one more time between neurons
it's does and on multiple layers well
it's you can see here that that it's
it's traveling vertically um I can't
remember exactly whether they go from
the superficial layers to the deep
layers I think they don't but just here
definitely pay at all 2008 I'll send you
the reference it's just a little-known
fact about the specific about this grid
that that's again it's kind of great
when you see grid like things you know
the engineer inside you goes oh my god
that's that's not something that I could
probably understand yes different types
of neurons so the different morphology
primarily to implement different types
of connectivity rather than different
functions so this would be a neuron that
has a very specific morphology so due to
induce a particular kind of connectivity
so what your stand on this I mean to say
that that inhibitory neurons might in
terms of function might be similar but
you need different types in order to
have yeah I mean it sort of looks like
it it mean
I mean inhibitory neurons can have more
than just they can be different from
each other more than just how do they
target their targets do they target them
by like basket cells cover the cell body
with with inhibitory contacts in a
basket you know and and somatostatin
cells kind of sprinkle the inputs more
distantly these cells hit a column yeah
so those but are it could be that the
actual synapses themselves behave
similarly they release GABA they
activate similar conductances you know
so yes morphology in the targeting
pattern is a major differentiator
between inhibitory neurons and it's part
of what gives the circuit its
personality the difference between a v1
and and a primary like a barrel cortex
where whisker input is coming in which
is a totally different signal I mean you
can imagine something so different is
that or sound sounds from images you're
gonna get the tailoring of the circuit
is going to be some some of it's gonna
be which inhibitory neurons are being
recruited in which ways to do what
things and that's part of the
flexibility
this of this system so just to summarize
that is to say that okay we still think
this is a two layer model but the the
subunits are more complex they're more
they're more elaborate they have these
nonlinear spatial intrinsic spatial
processing capabilities analog
processing capabilities that and I'm
representing that as a as a little multi
to D Sigma light there so it's kind of
departing from a conventional neural
network in that sense but although we're
still talking about a cell body that's
summing some of them together yes
is it exactly the same picture that is
like multi-dimensional you mean this
okay
that's the exact next thing I'm talking
about okay so if you have one input you
can get different sigmoids depending on
location if you had two inputs you could
get a 2-d sigmoid what's the limit of N
and see good that was a perfect time for
that question
yeah what goes here like if we had a
thousand inputs do you have a thousand
dimensional sigmoid are you saying yes
well okay here's the reason to not get
too excited well first of all actually
the thing I'm gonna leave you with
before we get out of this room which is
in 20 minutes I'm gonna I we want to
make sure that we're not as we kind of
go down this path and we you know
abstraction gone wild we do not want to
keep finding ever more complicated stuff
and getting really excited about how
great that is until we have some feeling
that there might be a bit that there
might have some applicability to natural
computation so I'm going to show you
that next but yes this is a question
that your just mind locks on to when you
see okay 1d 2d and then I can you know
three oh wow brilliant well so what
about n how but the thing that weighs
against you know this being like a
million and having a million dimensional
sigmoid here is that remember that as
you add more inputs to a dendrite they
become closer together
and since dendrites have argued on
cables and things travel are smooth and
and you know some of you move something
over 1 micron it's not gonna make any
difference whatsoever so you're gonna
reach some kind of a limit where you
can't tell you get no further benefit
you reach a diminishing return of having
or trying to describe it with a higher
dimensional sigmoid sure it'll look
it'll be a 10 dimensional sigmoid but
it's not going to look different than
the 5 d sigmoid or something like that
so what is the limit so we we
investigated this and this was something
with leijen my students where do you max
out and the way we did it was we took we
took a dendrite this is actually not a
fake I mean it's like
a real dendrite morphology sticking out
of a pyramidal neuron and we had a
compartmental model of this and we
applied we we just spatially varied
differently the same number of inputs so
we took 24 total excitatory synapses and
we activated them either in random
positions one clusters of one or and
here's a few of those and here's a few
choose where the twos went together and
here's some threes in your four is six
24 divides a lot of ways that's why we
use 24 and then we could have one where
we had literally all 24 synaptic
contacts at one point along the length
of the dendrite and what we the goal of
this was and this was this comes back to
my I want to be able to do this with a
piece of paper pencil and piece of paper
so here was the algorithm that we wanted
to try to use to predict how the cell
would respond to every possible one of
these patterns that you could generate
easily with a pencil and paper so what
would you do what you first you do is
you run zillions of these okay you're
gonna bunch of these around couples do
these all most of these and you collect
the data now then what what what what do
we then what do we how do we represent
that the data what we're gonna do is
we're going to take bins little lengths
of the dendrite and you know if I'm how
many bins are there 1 2 3 4 there's 5
bins in this case but there could have
been two there could have been 3 there
could have been 4 and there could have
been 5 and that was all that we went to
it was 5 and then we would just simply
count how much how many felons are this
bin okay so if it was this case then
like these all would have fallen is that
bin so I would get like seven in that
bin and not in this bin and none of this
bin and for in this bin and three in
this bin so we'd have we would turn a
stimulation pattern into just a bin
count and we would just store that
firing rate that we got from running the
simulation we run a simulation we would
get a firing rate and then we would put
that firing rate into a table that was
indexed by how many fell into each of
these bins how many synapses literally
just drop down into these columns and
counted does everybody see the algorithm
I mean what we did so we generated tens
of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
examples like this and then all we asked
was when we generated a new example
across validation set and we
but we counted how many synapses fell
into each of these bins and we looked up
into the table and we said well how many
spikes per second are we supposed to get
from these kinds of examples on average
and it's 23 spikes per second we can
then run that simulation and compare it
to 23 spikes per second and see how good
a prediction we got ok that's what we
did and here is the quality of those
predictions if we had two bins here's
what we would predict and here's what
actually happens and you know we get a
correlation of 0.56
r-squared right three bins point seven
eight four bins point eight nine five
bins 0.94 basically by the time you had
five bins you could pretty much get a
very accurate representation of what's
coming out of this thing here's what you
know if you want to look at it if you
want to think of this as an asymptote so
from the point of view of spatial
integration of excitatory inputs on a
dendrite this sigmoid little thing kind
of gets up to you know but by the time
you're already here you know even here
is pretty you're getting pretty good
you're pretty much nailing down the
spatial analog computing capability of
that dendrite in a purely excitatory key
I keep saying that as a caveat
there's no inhibition here but it's
still interesting to know from a pure
excitatory point of view and the answer
is about five dimensions of
computational nonlinear bonafide
non-linearity because it that's that's
how many basis functions essentially
these bins it takes to predict how well
or predict well how what's coming gonna
be produced by the neuron yes yeah so
that's a good point lay tried four five
you would try every possible five so he
would how do you divide up five this
thing into five bins there's a lot of
weights right I can't tell you what the
number is somebody here probably can't
it's some set theory thing or something
you know how many ways can add numbers
add up to this and so he would try every
possible one and then this would be the
best one or there would be some that
were best and that's the one that's
shown so you can predict this well with
a five this particular file
you could find different shaped five
bins that wouldn't be as good well if
the B if you had four bins there were
one micron long and then the fifth
minute you could say just it's you can't
answer that I can't give you a good you
know a satisfying answer to that
question but there but we we have to
admit that there would sometimes be
slight different bidding kind of things
that would would produce similar results
so we don't ountry aliy know exactly
what the pattern was you know why it
seemed like it was better to have kind
of finer representation in the middle
and maybe less representation at the end
there's there may be a biophysical
reason why that's true but we didn't get
to the bottom of that it's a way to it's
a way that I can this is a pencil and
paper thing that I said you put you
specify I'm gonna put the synapses here
and I'm gonna activate them at this rate
and then I'm gonna take I'm gonna just
kind of much excitation goes into the
five bins and I'm gonna look it up in my
table on my piece of paper I'm gonna say
you're gonna get 40 spikes per second
and that's my prediction and then we do
the simulation and this is what comes
out and that's how well I can do so I
can predict the compartmental model and
we know the compartmental model is a
pretty good predictor of the neuron so I
would say I'm very pleased with this it
means that that that pencil and paper
model I think this is what makes me
think it has a shot of working because
we know that like if I could predict the
excitatory Pat you know the response to
what's coming out of one dendrite and I
know that the dendrites kind of add the
results of the cell body
you know I'm flying my way to having a
model to predict the whole thing now we
have to include in addition in this and
we have not and that's going to be more
complicated so we do notice how well
that was gonna actually work
okay I I'm gonna skip
you know what it is I'm gonna just say
this so that you can enjoy this but it's
something that you should it really just
troubles you which is this is what
happens in a real neuron when it starts
getting excited here a current is being
injected in here
and do you see the neuron fires an
action potential do you see that the
entire basal dendritic tree just lit up
like a you know firecracker or whatever
so in that moment when an action
potential is generated the voltage
signal in the entire dendritic tree is
like it's like hitting the Clear button
every branch every place on every branch
it just gets gets set to get to of the
same voltage at the same time so it has
a it's like a reeseville this reset
button on the dendritic tree this is
very problematic if every so this could
be happening if the cell is firing 50
times a second that means 50 times a
second it's like going quickly clear
clear clear clear clear clear - the
voltage signal in the dendritic tree 50
times a second this is voltage at the
cell body oh this this is the apical
dendrite of a pyramidal neuron I'm
really calling your attention I'm sorry
I meant to call your attention to this
part of the basal tree because these
dendrites are all kind of the same and
they contain like half of the synapses
of the neuron this is a different part
of the neuron which I'm actually not
talking about but I should have said
that but i'm janie if you sort of look
at the this thing kind of just it
flashes you know just sort of slow flash
so that's it that's a brief annihilation
of the voltage of any voltage
information in the dendritic tree many
times a second how could this not
destroy the computation going on which
is voltage dependence
I mean and supposed to be having
separate integrated voltage things going
on in different dendrites well okay
now you're asking what is it for but I'm
asking why doesn't it destroy any every
time right no that would be why to have
it but I'm saying okay I mean I'm saying
why does this not destroy the in depend
and the vote these sensitive
voltage-dependent processing the
dendrites I'm gonna answer that in a
second linearly superimpose signal so
the underlying signal still there it's
just sort of everything raised and then
drops down again well I wouldn't call it
linear and saying that everything is
still there is an interesting thing to
say and that's sort of there's a spirit
of Weeden which that's true so I'm gonna
I'm gonna just show you some experiments
that we did that make a point well let
me tell you what let me tell you how we
what we did and just and then I'll tell
you quickly the answer here I'm kind of
breaking what it is I said I would do
but I think it's kind of its kind of
interesting so we could put like in
using a simulation we use the simulation
to study this issue we could put two
inputs here remember that would generate
because of their separation and whatever
that would generate this sigmoid and or
this input output curve and we could put
two here and that would generate a
different input up occur because these
have different positions and it's not of
different dendrite and we would what we
would do is we would figure out we would
just activate this one branch by itself
and we would we would then record what
happens to the cell body and that's what
this graph is branch bees graph and this
is branch's graph separately from you
know from just just doing it by itself
and then the question is as we put this
many synapses on branch be here and you
know proximal just these two locations
and we put this many you know some point
here at these two locations and then we
just use that setting to predict what
this branch is going to put out we grab
that number and then we grab the number
from here
can we just add those two numbers and
that's what the cell bodies going to do
so that's what we did and okay and well
that's that's kind of the logic of this
actually here okay unfortunately I'm
showing you an example we just had one
the input for the blue is this signal
end and the response for the red one was
this sigmoid and we would just put a
combination of two inputs we would read
the group you know how much was on the
blue we read that number off how much
was on the red would be that number off
we'd add the two numbers and put it into
the somatic fi curve and say that's our
prediction and when we did that we would
get predicted responses like this
the actual responses were like this and
the error was like that he
was virtually perfect and look this cell
is firing at a hundred spikes per second
so for whatever reason it's an
incredibly sort of linear summing device
from the point of view of summing the
effects of the different branches
despite the fact that it's firing like
crazy all the while that there's
nonlinear voltage dependent stuff going
on in the dendrites and we did we do so
we did the same thing with with two
inputs I here I'm gonna I this is where
we analyzed it and I'm not going to tell
you about this and I'll tell you the
result actually I'll just show you here
because I think Wolfgang maybe you're
the one who said or somebody said you
said it just leaves things alone right
the basic reason is that these
underlying waveforms that are produced
by the synapses that have to do with
these NMDA things are relatively slight
slow time course events and they are
relatively briefly interrupted by these
action potentials the action potential
comes and goes and then this the silt
the the condition of the state of that
dendrite goes back to just what it was a
millisecond before and so these
perturbations are very very brief and
they do not change the overall contour
of the of the of the currents that are
injected from the synapses and so if I
if I were to and I'm going to skip this
I'm gonna skip that it's kind of
interesting but I'm just going to show
you these predictions if we add two
inputs at two locations on two different
dendrites producing these two separate
things if we use that simple algorithm
we just pretend what's coming out of
this one by independently what's coming
out of this one independently we ran
hundreds of thousands of cases and we
made the prediction by adding those two
numbers together putting it into the
somatic IV curve reading off a
prediction and here were the actuals and
here were the predictions our squared
equals 0.9999
so despite this apparent crazy
synchronizer of the cell body it
actually is helping to we showed was it
actually helps to because the cell is
firing action potentials in a maximum
selves are very stereotyped and they
return the voltage back to a stereotyped
place they help isolate the voltage
changes in the different dendrites from
each other and they create a more
independent subunits so we have a paper
about this if you're interested and
anyway so that reassure
the two-layer model is still a good a
good workhorse because even when you
have nonlinear things going on in the
subunits the second layer appears to
still behave rather simply yes now you
seem to say that if you have these
spikes and the voltage propagated to the
dendrite that helps in this linear
superposition of the contributions of
the different compartments so your
simulation can you sort of turn off the
spikes and show that them this the
superposition is less linear oh god that
was a perfect question that's what this
graph is that I skipped is basically
showing that what we don't want to have
is that voltages currents coming out of
one dendrite affect the input output
curve of the other dendrite that's what
we don't want because that's a crosstalk
thing and that means that we can't tell
what this dendrites gonna spit out it
depends on what's going on in other
dendrites then they're no longer
independent so this is showing the input
output curve of a dendrite being
affected by what's coming from the cell
body and we don't want it to be affected
so what happens is when the cell is at
rest then this is the input upper curve
of that dendrite if the cell is
depolarized at the cell body by somebody
else then that guys in put up a curve
shifts a lot it shifts from here to here
which is a huge threshold change but
then the minute the cell starts to fire
action potentials one spike per second
fifty spikes per second one hundred
spikes per second the epidemic curve is
just locked down and it's no longer
affected by how much the cell bodies
being activated by other guys it's kind
of amazing yes Murray the membrane time
constant spread out the the back
propagating action
there's some of that you know an action
potential will become a little bit
fatter as it moves out of dendrite this
has been people have done back
propagating air but it still is still
like a 1 millisecond long thing you know
a couple milliseconds of the mouse I
mean I can show you I mean we stood a
simulation and you could their studies
of this there's a little bit more to it
you know that's another we're sort of
second-order effects that are going on
here and that I didn't really have time
to I think I'm gonna just have to skip
to the skip to the end here because
we've run out of time but so there's a
there's a section which that I want to
get to or just the last slide I want to
get to I was going to show you an
application I mean I was gonna show you
where if sigmoids come from and then
actually or where they are found we
found a place where I'll just show you
this one picture and just tell you and
then maybe we have trying to talk later
we found we measured something in
natural images a nonlinear interaction
between different places and natural
images to in the in the context of
contour detection in natural images we
actually collected natural images we
labeled contours we looked at
interactions between Center and flanker
inputs and we found that the interaction
between them in order to compute contour
probability and natural images something
that neuron needs to do to detect
contours in natural images Oh is a is a
two-dimensional signal function and if
you were to take inputs these values and
put them onto the dendrite at two
different locations it would produce
that function and that function that the
black frame is the same in both graphs
so this is a this is what the dendrite
likes to do and does naturally and from
based on its biophysics that's a natural
visual computation of having to do with
contour detection it's a
multi-dimensional sigmoid shape so we
have one example in our hands of a where
we with the first place we looked
there's you you see these types of
relationships between sort of a primary
variable and a modulatory variable they
crop up so we think that the hardware is
it exactly the right spot it needs to be
to to help perform these computations
okay and with that I'm going to go to my
last line
oh yeah look I had Jeff look-ins slide
in here Oh God
never
oh here it is yeah so why don't we learn
this has to do with like when you look
at stuff in the brain what should you
see and one thing you should see is this
is an ER this reminds me those CNN
commercials this is an Apple this is not
a banana have you seen those are you
having no you don't watch enough TV for
them so that is an Iran the way that we
think about an Iran it's as elaborate
and complicated as it is it really is
like a point in Iran they don't like a
conventional pointing around and and
then then this is not an Iran this is an
Iran well I mean I'm you know I'm making
a point where the thing that we used to
think neurons are is a little
integrative unit that generates a local
spike it's sort of like one of these and
I mean but would you wouldn't have known
it and then this is actually in fact
this thing because of these kind of
spatial effects in a ways a more
complicated nonlinear processor than
that thing so that's one kind of
interesting one kind of interesting
thing and and actually what you would
call that is you would say that is
thirty complicated neurons with a shared
learning signal so I didn't talk about
this but that back propagating spike
that comes out a lot of people think
that that's to help to sort of inform
for plasticity in the dendrites it kind
of creates a synchronized plasticity
signal so that these dendrites are all
learning under the same signal when the
soma fires it sends the voltage out into
the dendritic tree everybody gets it
every synapse gets to feel it so they
all know that the soma spikes and so if
you want to have an sctp rule or some
kind of a rule they get broadcast that
signal and they all get the same one so
it's different to group a dendrite
together into this neuron versus the
next neuron over which gets a different
signal and then this is not an
interconnection it's a synapse that's an
interconnect so we when you when you
want to think about the functional
interconnections between neurons this
notion that it's just an excitatory or
inhibitory wait he's overly simple
because the the the way that neurons
probably like to interact with each
other and they'll probably get more
useful abstraction of what an
interconnection looks like in the court
is that it's something that that creates
a conjoint excitatory inhibitory effect
distributed possibly non uniformly
across the dendritic trees of a cell of
being that's being targeted so it's like
a higher dimensional interconnection
weight or interconnection it's like a
multi dimensional interconnection in the
same way that these are like multi
dimensional signals so we're getting
it's an odd computer and it's an
exciting computer to be to be studying
and we're still I mean you know there's
so much just it's mind-boggling but
anyway I hope you get you get some ideas
from this and help you in your own work
[Applause]
that's the self filter the mouth that's
like opposed to the interests of actress
well the the the wait no I the way that
we would say that is that we studied
cases where there was sort of a longer
time course there's a train of inputs
being delivered to synapses over a
period of time which is long compared to
the the brief period that an action
potential that an action potential last
which is on the order of a millisecond
so if the cells receiving you know when
you fixate an object envisioned
typically a fixation last 300
milliseconds so you know maybe that's a
reasonable amount of time you know a
third of a second or a fraction of a
second where your brain is is
integrating the signal from from
something that's long compared to the
period of an action potential which is
like a millisecond and so we think of
that what's happening in the dendrite is
being on a slow time course and these
interruptions as being very very brief
and so they don't mess with the voltage
signal for very long they don't alter
the currents that those synapses would
inject very much and that's what kind of
helps that's why they don't perturb very
much the computations going on bitter
depended on the voltage dependence of
the NMDA channel yeah yes and that's
what I was so you're talking
great so this what we've been talking
about what I've been focusing on are
these thin dendrites that like peri
somatic thin dendrites or oblique
dendrites on an iPhone if you activate
the apical tuft you can get calcium
spikes which is a different type of a
biophysical mechanism which are yes they
can be much longer lasting but they
haven't they seem to that's not the main
blocking calcium channels in these
dendrites does not make NMDA spikes go
away it can just were changes a little
bit but it's not they're not a big
current carrier in dendrites the thin
dendrites yes in this pursuit of
abstraction gone wild would you say
there's anything about that pyramidal
cell it could not be reduced to a
network of simple neurons they point
you're replacing each dendrite for
example by a well so you know the
computer scientists in everyone wants to
doesn't see any distinction between if I
call this a point neuron and then they
all add together and then this whole
thing is just a big summer point neurons
it's just two layers of a network and I
would I don't care with it which what
you call a neuron or not I can just I
could draw a circle around this many
units in a diagram and say okay that's
what a real neuron actually corresponds
to but we wouldn't care from a
computational point of view but the so
the only thing I think well there's the
way that the different subunits of the
neuron are more related to each other
inside an ER and then they would be
between neurons is is kind of an answer
to your question and I don't I I can't
make a super super compelling I just I
said one idea which is that they
certainly share a learning signal at a
time learning signal which they share
those private to that neuron they also
share the modular Tory state that that
you know there's a modulatory state that
is sort of affected by the typical tuft
which will be shared between them too so
neurons actually have a meaning I mean
you know when you look in the visual
cortex new record from a neuron it
typically has a receptive field that's
somehow interpretable it's it's responds
to some kinds of objects and
No and somehow things that want to
modulate like your if you want to attend
to a certain object you want to tend to
a certain location or you want to tend
to a certain you know you're looking for
a vertical there there's ways that in
which you might want to modulate all of
the subunits of a neuron together and
differently and from the next neuron
over so but yes I think we're not going
to be blown away by the ways that you
know your question I died the spirit of
the question is exactly correct how much
should we care that a bunch of different
subunits is grouped within one neuron
versus we just you know and and but I
think the groupings have to do with
plasticine have to do with modulation
I was just so getting back to the five
dimensional thing so if I understood it
correctly with the right signal right
like within the right opening like what
in some length but then drive you don't
need more than five synapses so let you
kind of make me to some like sparse it's
not you just need some sparse nothing
connections oh let me see no no I I
didn't say that I was just saying that
you know a typical dendrite like one of
these centers might be covered with a
couple hundred contacts and the kind of
you know all along I mean you saw those
pictures that Jeff had yesterday now
we're just saying that you could if you
want to know what the dendrites gonna do
as it gets stimulated and you there's
some pattern of excitation coming in
along its length you can sort of think
of it as being Bend and okay there's the
ones that are kind of close to the soma
there's the ones that are here there's
the ones that are here how much
excitation is coming it at several
different sort of lengths along the
dendrite and just by knowing that kind
of some you know like binning of how
much stuff fell here here here here and
here you could take those five numbers
and that allows you to predict what that
dendrite is going to put out so you look
it up on the table we said in all the
case cases in which you had this much
section at these five light places
here's the average firing rate that was
produced in those cases and she's that's
your best guess so you guessed that and
then you find you find that you actually
get something very close to that it's a
good predictor yes Brian's question
easily can you replace this for the
Russian point neurons so you at the
beginning you introduced this
two-dimensional landscape but morphology
and dynamics so it seems like we've been
talking a lot about morphology but you
know so when we think about the dynamics
things like coincidence detection and
that might come into play yeah that's a
that's a very good point I've been kind
of focusing this entire time on on
spatial processing so well Brittany you
just said something there's two things
that you might as you said a network of
point neurons okay we've already kind of
established that these types of
dendrites don't look like point neurons
but they could still be a network of
neurons that are a little bit more
complicated that do have spatial
processing in them but they do have
still have temporal processing - that's
an additional complication but then
we'll probably then we're just gonna get
to a point where those things can be
interesting analog spatial processors
and animal interesting analog temporal
processors it just generalized it just
makes the subunit more complicated but
yeah which is fine we've already made it
more complicated we can make it more
more complicated by adding time in there
but that's a good question what what
does it become when we had time and and
that's that opens up a huge thing but
but it still we still may have a bunch
of more complicated units that some in
within a neuron that may still be a
valid abstraction but as far as we can
tell it sort of is but so that's kind of
the answer to your question is maybe as
long as and so we find a really bad like
breaking of the prediction that the
effects of these things kind of combine
very simply in the linear' way then
maybe it's okay to just call them a
bunch II you know a bunch of units that
share a training signal right so so in
the middle of your talk I thought well
great even though the neurons
complicated I can use a standard new a
network simulate everything because
that's the standard or network but then
you said the share learning signal I
mean they also follow that information
through one axon right that's the other
thing that's yeah that's true drop it
some so I was wondering with this
now I mean does this have a particular
function we do you see particular
learning problems where this would be
useful as compared to a more general
network or is this just the cheap way of
getting sort of a lot of computational
units is that not quite as universal as
a network but it's much cheaper
biological to get that so is there a
function for this justice that's a good
question and I wouldn't try to give you
a general answer and then if there's a
general answer in the cortex that may
not be the same as in the striatum I
mean or wherever else we look but one of
the ways that that this relates to
things that we may have thought about
elsewhere everybody I mean all of us is
to think about the multiple subunits of
a neuron well might they be and a lot of
people who've been interested in vision
and who can remember back to to
Fukushima and so on you know we all like
the idea that a neuron pools together
subunits that represent shifted or
translated or rotated or something
viewpoint varying versions of the same
thing could be pulled together inside a
unit and create a morts invariant
receptive field a complex cell if I may
say it that way
and so we're very used to that idea and
here beloved Cuba David Hubel said it
you know that you could have dendrites
being the simple two subunits of a more
like a complex cell and so as you move
through the visual system there is a
progression towards more larger and
larger pools of things that are more and
more complex and I believe that that's
going to turn in to be that it's the
dendrites that are the pools
you know the collections of dendrites
within are the pools I mean I mean it's
not a huge leap from this it's something
that we've always thought yes so that's
that's one reason why you might be
building pools inside neurons because
they represent the same thing under sort
of you know but but they're helping to
absorb variations in the stimulus by
making the neuron respond to all of them
you know we have a couple people over
here
sorry [ __ ] about what happens to right
just give us one
yeah I didn't talk about that people
have done work on this and they believe
that this is kind of a global modulator
of the neuron where kind of sets the
game for the whole neuron like all the
subunits and Matthew Larkin is one of
the main people who's kind of done the
experimental work behind that Walter Sen
had a paper modeling paperwork earth
wasn't no I don't think he's been so
much of a lot of people will descend and
Markham did paper on that and that's
kind of I accept that I think we should
great Greg Bruno because yeah
[Applause]